if you can't get enough of Dodge
Chargers dragging bank vaults around the
streets of Rio or million-dollar sports
cars jumping between skyscrapers then
you'll be glad to know plans for Fast &
Furious 8 are well underway I'm Simon
and this is your rapid and raging news
updates following the news last week
that Mad Max fury road charlize theron
was joining Fast & Furious 8 it's now
been confirmed that another series
newcomer Scott Eastwood has come aboard
the run plays the action movies main
villain however there is no information
yet as to the roll eastward the son of
legendary actor and director Clint
Eastwood will play in the film let's
hope he's feeling lucky punk deadline
first reported the news before eastward
himself tweeted about his involvement
the Furious franchise is known for its
big names such as Vin Diesel Michelle
Rodriguez and Paul Walker alongside
newer entries such as Dwayne the rock
Johnson Tyrese Gibson and Jason Statham
however Walker tragically died in a car
crash in 2013 and Furious 8 will be the
first entry in the series that he won't
appear in Furious 8 is just the latest
high-profile project phase with as it
also be seen in this summer's Suicide
Squad and Oliver Stone Snowden in
September earlier this year it was
confirmed that there would be at least
two more films in the Furious franchise
with parts 9 and 10 during 20 19 and 20
21 star and producer Vin Diesel's plans
for even more movies was revealed last
year when he stated I promised the
studio would deliver one last trilogy to
end the saga the actor has also hinted
that additional spin-off movies could be
made focusing on some of the individual
characters from the action series Fast &
Furious 8 will open on April 14 2017 are
you looking forward to more wacky racing
adventures or have you had enough of
burnt rubber and cheesy one-liners leave
your comments will hook me up on twitter
i'm at the j connaught thanks for
watching and for all your entertainment
news keep it gamespot's